it was the 20th century's first genocide
an estimated 100,000 ethnic Herero and
nama people died at the hands of German
colonial troops in present-day Namibia
between the Year 1904 1905 for a long
time
Berlin refused to call the killings a
genocide but that changed back in 2015
Germany and Namibia are now in talks
about a joint declaration on the
massacre
while the killings were carried out by
the then German Empire they took place
in the area in southern Africa now known
as Namibia at the time the territory was
known as german south-west africa in
1904 German soldiers crushed an uprising
by the Herero and nama people's against
their colonial rulers the colonizers
response was brutally simple they drove
the fleeing nama and her arrows into the
desert where many died of starvation
while tens of thousands of people were
killed and more perished in the
repression that followed 80% of the
entire herrera population and half of
the nama population died while the
leaders of both indigenous groups are
calling for reparations from the German
government and say anything else would
be an insult to the victims descendents
and I want to wish you a very warm
welcome to both of our guests I'm joined
in the studio to discuss the Herero and
nama genocide with me are Ida Hofmann
chair of the nama genocide committee and
a member of the Namibian government our
parliament I should say and Esther my
own Yong gwee of the OVA Herrera or
genocide foundation a thank you so much
ladies for being a widow sir I greatly
appreciated Esther I want to start off
with you these talks are taking place
but you're actually quite critical of
these talks explain to us why okay thank
you very much I'm very happy to be here
I'm very happy to be at the Berlin
conference this is a Berlin conference
of 2016
not the Berlin Conference of 1884 1885
where they decided as to who you take
Africa so currently we are hearing that
the two governments are
he started with the negotiations the
talks are going on but we are critical
because for us the process is very
flawed the way the approach is totally
wrong
I find first how is it flawed how is it
wrong
why do what you say it is wrong in the
first place that who has decided that
there should be two special envoys
appended it was the two governments
without our knowledge so you feel left
out we fear we are totally excluded in
the process did you feel the same way
miss Hoffman right in much the same way
we are exploited and but you're here for
these talks so evidently you
participating as well and you can voice
all your concerns yeah but now we are
wasting our concerns with NGOs not with
the government because then the German
government refused to be part of this
Congress and that is also a sign of they
are not genuine because if they are
genuine why is it making it so difficult
for them to talk to us so we are here to
do to try to fight our case but we are
not here we were so hoping to meet the
German government representatives but
everyone is like no we don't have time I
will not be around and so on your
organization's are calling for
restorative justice
what is restorative justice what does
that mean restorative justice it simply
means that if you have done damage you
repair that damage and how can you
repair that damage that damage to repair
that damage that is what we are saying
let the Yemen government sit with the
descendents of the communities that were
you know cited so that we can talk and
we tell them and it's not difficult
because the German government is paying
the Jewish communities for the Holocaust
so the German government knows how to do
this because that is something that they
are doing already so they don't need to
be taught by us as to how they should do
it I want to bring miss Hoffman into the
conversation because this is
one of the arguments that you're using
as well is that they should there should
be a paid reparations for the atrocities
that have taken place how do you put a
dollar value on atrocities how do you
determine that first of all is that we
demand revelation revelation was demand
in the parliament no maybe a parliament
way the motion was addressed the
solution was been taken that the German
government and the nama harer all these
people under the extermination order of
three to October 1904 22april of Canton
of I must can insert around the table
with the German government the Namibian
government will only be the mediator
that means that the round table
acknowledgment apology reparation
repatriation and and and restitution
that is it yes when we talk about this
it was accepted in the parliament
it was a great in the Parliament all of
the sudden it comes now where our
government come and play a role because
our government have not thought that we
will fight this fight until to the end
so do you feel that your government is
letting you down is your government lay
you down in earnest in this in this
instance in this together with the
German government all right well let's
let's talk about back into 2004 the
Germany's then Development Minister went
in Namibia presented his apologies an
official apology what kind of response
are you hoping for right now I'm gonna
start with you and then I'd like to have
also your response as well that apology
you see that she did lend a to go
instead of the people and
colleges for what it has happened it was
a gathering where the herons have called
up and she was there together with the
then president Bahama yes after after
when people demand reparation
talk about this it is where she stand up
and she apologize now apology means for
me that when you sit and you talk to the
people you said I have done this to you
I have done the steel I have done this
to you based on these things that I have
done to you
that is way I really online is all you
can be stained but you said please can't
you Apple can you take my apology can
you forgive me I want to get and have
what were you expecting hoping for and I
am always asking the question that when
fro hey Tamara Visser exile said the
apology was it official I don't think it
was official apology what makes you
think it was not horse who came there in
an official capacity exactly but what
happened when she came back from Namibia
she almost was crucified who gave her
the right to go and apologize those were
the questions that were put to her and
if the German government is serious
about apologizing why is it so difficult
for them to adopt the emotions that have
been put in there more Emir Buddha stuck
by the left party in 2007 and recently
since Lee last year those motions were
put they and the codec that the Buddha
stock could not succeed to come up with
an official apology and that make me to
wonder that are they really genuine all
right so there's still a lot of work
they done - and on the question will
bring about reconciliation thank you
ladies thank you so very much
we greatly appreciate your coming in
thank you very much thank you so much